I think it's very important to make
clear this is a really ambitious project
it is to ensure that we change the power
coming into this country we have clean
Power by 2030 and that means lower bills
you can see why that's really important
to people at the moment energy security
so Putin can never do what he's doing
now and try to put his boot on our
throat ever again and there are hundreds
of thousands of jobs tied up in this but
it's linked I mean you talk to me about
education and the Health Service and I
understand that it's linked to this
because we do need more money in our
Public Services they're they're not just
on their knees they're on their face
we've got to pick them up make them fit
for the future but in order to do that
we've got to grow our economy we've had
almost no growth effective growth for
the last 13 years we've got to turn
around it falls to us to do it so these
these are not in contrast to what we're
doing with the NHS they're part and
parcel of the same argument and you how
do we judge success because you you've
talked about clean Power by 2030 how
many jobs will this create by the end of
next Parliament how many jobs over a
decade were the direct number of jobs is
two hundred thousand two hundred and
eighty thousand on top of that that's
just in clean power there's up to a
million across the board and there's a
very important part of the announcement
that I have made in my speech day which
is the British jobs bonus and this is
making sure that the jobs are here in
the UK because wherever I go wherever I
go to a wind farm or any other
infrastructure project and ask where
were these made the answer is always
somewhere else I want that to change I
want those jobs to be here in the UK but
it's okay just because that that's
that's not net jobs is it because there
will be job losses in oil and gas well
the existing jobs in oil and gas under
existing licenses obviously will
continue for decades to come because
those licenses will continue through to
the 2050s but this is about the next
generation of jobs but it's also
something very very important which
which is making sure that if the supply
chains things that need to be made in
these infrastructure projects that
they're made here in the UK I went to
whiteley's which is the wind farm just
outside Glasgow there are hundreds of
turbines there and I asked the question
how many of these were made in Scotland
or the United Kingdom and the answer was
none of them because the government
we've got now didn't have a strategic
plan I'm not going to allow that to
happen again so I want to come back onto
the British jobs for British workers
brown brown overtones there sometimes
people call you the heir of Blair but I
think that's Gordon Brown isn't it
British jobs for British workers I feel
passionately that these jobs should be
in the United Kingdom I my dad was in
Engineering in manufacturing and that
was allowed to dwindle coal mines we
allowed those to be closed down without
any plan for the future we're still
feeling the effects of that I'm not
going to let that happen we have skilled
people we have Innovation we have
fantastic people prepared you know for
the next generation of jobs they need a
government that and ensures that those
jobs are here just in terms of targets
so you know you've got a big job job
Target insight
just to be clear clean Power by 2030 so
all of our electricity from renewals is
that a guarantee or is it a Target it's
it's the ambition and it's doable so
it's not a guarantee because you might
fall short because it is so ambitious
what I've done is I've sat down with the
sector and said this is what I want to
achieve is it possible for us to achieve
it so it's not just a Target that hasn't
been thought through centrika who as you
know you know responsible for a lot of
the supply of gas have said it's tough
but it's doable what they want what we
want is a partnership where we roll up
our sleeves and get on with it it's
going to mean tough decisions so
planning needs to be changed the grid
needs to be changed take too long for
these projects okay we're going to turn
that around right okay but just let's
get into oil and gas quickly you say
this is all about secure in the future
but is this your self-interest too
because you've personally received tens
of thousands of pounds in donations from
delvins the Green Power Tycoon who funds
just stop oil
to clear this up are you going to take
any more money from him look this has
got nothing to do with donations to the
labor party it's to do with the
transition
just hit me up the oil and gas in the
North Sea is dwindling 90 of the gas is
already extracted or is already under
existing licenses so we know we've got
to make this change nobody's arguing but
most of the sector already putting most
of their money in their resources into
Renewables so this is a plan that's
actually listening to the sector and no
donut the labor party has any influence
on policy or any discussion of money
from him well look I've taken the
donations from him so far he has
absolutely no role in policy and
wouldn't countenance not with any donor
but this is this is a serious plan about
the future jobs for Scotland the future
of the United Kingdom establishing GB
energy so that where we put public money
in from the UK we get the yield back out
for the United Kingdom these are
fundamentals to an economy which will
deliver for working people across the
whole United I've just got two more
things would you resolve from the idea
that this is a policy if you forgive the
trumpian overtones of putting Britain
fast well look I do want those jobs to
be here in Britain I'm not going to
apologize for that I think when I went
and looked at those turbines
um in Glasgow just outside Glasgow 350
turbines and learned that not a single
one had been built in Britain whilst
workers here in Scotland who could have
built them are looking at them I'm going
to change that and I want to make sure
that those Supply chains are operating
here in the United Kingdom so that we
get the yield on the next generation of
jobs are you happy if people call your
protectionist would be prime minister I
don't think this is protectionist it's
about ensuring we've got the jobs here
in the United Kingdom I you know when I
look at the cost of living crisis when I
look at the pain people are suffering
under 13 years of economic failure I
want to turn that around and I want to
look British workers in the eye and say
I'll work with you to ensure that the
high-skilled well-paid secure jobs of
the future are with you here in this
country
okay contrarians would say that you were
the free marketeer single Market open
trading kirstama when you wanted to
remain in the European Union and now you
are seemingly a protectionist at heart
well the real kissed armor please stand
up I am determined to turn our economy
around and make it work for working
people so it's measured in living
standards across the whole of the United
Kingdom I know what it felt like to grow
up when we couldn't make ends meet I
know there are millions of families
going through the anxious decision my
family had to take I'm not going to
allow that continue I'm going to sit on
my hands and say the market can decide
I'm going to roll up my sleeves and say
we'll be an active government we'll
partner with businesses and together we
will deliver these jobs to the Future
and across the sector there's a ripple
of excitement about the prospect of a
government coming in that will serve the
people have a strategic plan and deliver
you know those jobs of the future the
prosperity of the future and ensure that
living standards for people rise right
across the whole of the United king